he is DeForest Buckner he plays for the
San Francisco 49ers native of Hawaii of
course in Oregon Duck as well how's the
celebration there in San Francisco after
that win huh it's really good thank you
for having me on the show there how and
I'm glad to have you on did you do you
guys go out as a team or like the
defense do you celebrate is that a big
deal
you know some guys a lot of guys will
team you know they go out and celebrate
but you know majority the guys have
family in town and you know since you
know celebrate with their families and
everything so my was one of those guys I
had a lot of family in town so you know
I celebrated with my family how many
tickets the Jets come up with about I
want to say about 14 okay that's that's
nothing about what about next week yeah
next week is gonna probably around 16 so
a lot of people you're gonna lose money
the longer you go in the playoffs here
and then if you get to the Super Bowl
and those are really expensive tickets
there you know I'm lucky a lot of my
family members that may be back because
they know it's coming out of my pocket
slow game plan versus Minnesota was what
defensively just stop the run stop the
run and make it a one-dimensional game
and that's what we did have you ever
looked around during it you know during
a game and gone oh my god like your
defense yesterday was spectacular but I
don't know if sometimes in the moment or
when you're watching film where you step
back as a fan or as an analyst just to
kind of marvel at what you're seeing
watching film you know in the moment you
know we're just we're hyped up for each
other playing for each other and uh you
know we're not thinking about numbers
it's just you know we're when we get out
there we want to get the ball back to
the office as fast as possible which is
whether it's three and outs or you know
getting the ball back in we did a really
good job with that
you know this past Saturday and you know
we're just watching the film you
definitely get hyped off with it
Niners defense had five sacks against
the Packers when you played them in
November
you had a half sack and held Aaron
Rodgers to 104 yards passing what do you
expect this time around that'll be
different from Rodgers in the game plan
yeah um I think you know those try to
establish the run game a little more I'm
obviously the man run ball well on these
recent weeks you know areas on a really
good connection with you know Davante
Adams and you know he saw his comment
how he said it kind of reminded him of
his connection with Jordy back in the
day so you know they're playing really
well you know they got a solid defense
you know they played hard on special
teams so I'm definitely gonna be a
different game you know a different type
you know a different hearing obviously
coming back to the bay you know they got
a chip on their shoulder you know coming
back and they didn't want to you know
obviously they want some your demson so
it's gonna be you know we're not
expecting the same team we saw earlier
in the year to use to say anything to
your court two opposing quarterbacks
during the game do you talk at all no I
don't really talk you leave that up to
Richard Sherman yeah sure Quan yeah I'll
let it all go guys
and when Bosa went down it looked like
he was really hurt
yes and then he pulled like he was WWE
where he got up like The Undertaker
right he just got the wind knocked down
I just got the wind knocked I think I
think all that sag Dean kind of saw all
them maybe I'm not sure but we all were
definitely concerned and when he got
back uh but we got through Sala and I
was like Nick that's a fine who did you
grow up rooting for since you grew up in
Hawaii the Chargers fan really and then
uh and I watched a lot of Saints games
my dad was a big was a big Saints fan
chain growing up so those are the two
teams I really wants now get ready for
are you ready for that Rodgers cadence
yeah now you can't jump arsenide you
can't yeah it's one of the best hard
cuts in the game and when when you go
all sides you know you gonna take that
shot down the field all right why don't
you get down in in your stance and I'll
play Rogers here and I know it's radio
but
this will be just good practice so I'm
in I'm in the gun here all right ready
yeah yeah I think you got me on now oh I
did did the yellow weasel you know
that's that's his hand that as an
audible last night I know I heard that
last night yeah what does yellow weasel
mean to you I uh you know it depends you
know you gotta constantly hear it
throughout the game you know and uh I
mean yesterday I lit a check to a run on
that one so they're probably gonna check
it you know it's all the same call the
same audible but make it different play
out of this for sure Disney we can play
it does Jimmy Garoppolo use product on
his hair prior to a game yes or no I
don't believe so
okay you know that's just that's just
natural it's all natural but I think
that's the wrong answer
I think Dryden Garoppolo pre-game
probably has a sponsorship where he uses
product on his hair maybe I'm not sure
I've never seen it is George Kindle the
craziest guy in the goofiest guy on the
team that's more like what would be
their favorite story like if you said
somebody says say what's George kiddo
like and you do you have a story that
you would tell about George that shows
he's just the overall Joker man you know
he just uh there was a plague I forgot
who was he it was against it might have
been an Atlanta where he made a block
and he pancake the guy and he was just
laughing you know the entire time haces
who saw it on film you can see his face
is just laughing the entire time so you
know he just thought he's just a joking
man well a lot of you can have a sense
of humor and laugh when you're playing
as well as you guys are but that was
very very impressive performance against
the Vikings that's it that's just I
likened it to the 85 Bears and the Super
Bowl with the Patriots I thought you
guys had every answer possible against
that offense and that offense had been
playing pretty well but the pressure you
put on Kirk Cousins I was really really
impressive and that's why I wanted to
have you on so we appreciate your time
and good luck this weekend divorce
alright thank you for having me again
that's a divorce Buckner
it turns 26 in March he grew up on Oahu
I believe for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]